في تطور جديد على الساحه السودانيه وعلى
وقع خلافات بينهما عقد كل من رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ونائبه محمد
حمدان حميدتي اجتماعا بمشاركه هي القوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي وفي ختام
مشاورات بشان الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه
قرر الاجتماع وتكوين لجنه الامنيه مشتركه
من القوات النظاميه واجهزه الدوله ذات
الصله وحركات الكفاح المسلح لمتابعه
الاوضاع الامنيه بالبلاد ووفقا لبيان صادر
عن مجلس السياده السوداني اقر الاجتماع
والموضيه فيما وصف بالترتيبات المتفق
عليها بشان العمليه السياسيه من جانبها
قالت مصادر قوى الحريه والتغيير مجموعه
المجلس المركزي للجزيره ان قيادات من قبل
الحريه والتغيير ناقشت في اجتماعها مع
البرهان وحميه ترتيبات الخاصه بورشه
الاصلاح العسك ري ضمن الورش الخاصه
بالعمليه السياسيه وصولا الى الاتفاق
النهائي